awesome
welcome caleb maupin thanks for joining
us
sure glad to be here
super excited for this it was uh great
to
talk to your colleague from cpi ryan
cotton and then
have him recommend you coming on the
show
yeah ryan's pretty cool heck yes
yeah and we'll be unpacking a lot more
of cpi at the center for political
innovation
the four-point plan we'll be talking
about caleb's background and how he got
to
being interested in what he's doing
today so
let's start with that caleb give us a
bit on your background and trajectory
and how you got
interested in what you're doing today
well i'm from a small town in ohio
uh i grew up in a little tiny town
called oroville ohio
it's where smucker's jelly is
manufactured it's maybe two hours south
of cleveland
uh a rural town like my graduating class
was a little over 100 people 115
and uh you know i remember you know from
an early age i was interested in
radical movements and such i remember
that uh you know my mother was a
librarian in stark county
and uh she and the other librarians they
were members of the seiu the service
employees international union and they
went on strike
when i was in fourth grade so i think
the first political thing i ever did was
as a fourth grader i walked the picket
lines with my mom that was pretty neat
um and uh well you know the iraq war
happened and i was very opposed to it
but my town was very conservative and
very supportive of it we had to do all
kinds of
pro-war stuff in school you know we had
to make these like candy packets for the
troops every morning and stuff
and i was kind of alienated from that so
that you know forced me to
argue with a lot of people and so i had
to learn a lot about you know the world
and that really opened my eyes
um i got to visit ecuador uh when i was
12 years old with my father who was you
know he had kind of a side gig leading
nature tours in the galapagos islands
so i got to go to ecuador with my dad
when he was there and i it was in the
middle of a
of a crisis of neoliberalism i mean i
remember getting off the airplane there
was just
crowds of starving people outside the
airport i'd never seen that level of
extreme poverty before 1999 was the year
i was there and
it was the country was just in turmoil
you know brought in by
the imf and the world bank and so as i
got into college i started doing uh
activism i got involved with some
radical groups i started doing radical
you know
studies and and classes and reading
groups but i also got involved in
protests against police brutality in
cleveland i actually video recorded
there was a walkout at a high school in
cleveland at collinwood high school
and i video recorded the walkout i heard
about it on facebook it was like 2010
and i heard about this walkout and i
went and i luckily i was there with my
camera because the police were very
violent to two young women just you know
just attacked them
uh and i videoed it in my video got one
of them acquitted in juvenile court um
so that was pretty exciting and
you know i went to court with some
police brutality victims and such and uh
you know around the time of uh 2011 i
moved to new york city
um and when i was in new york city i was
around the time of the occupy wall
street movement
um and so i was participating in the
occupy wall street movement i was
working at an insurance firm that was my
full-time job at the time but i
i would go every day after work and on
the weekends to go support occupy wall
street and i was working with
the international action center which
was a non-profit started by ramsey clark
who was the former u.s attorney general
who ever since you know nixon fired him
from being like
a real radical voice against war and
you know he represented saddam hussein
when he was on trial in iraq he
represented milosevic and
you know he would represent in
international court you know people the
us was going after
and uh you know he went to cuba a number
of times with vietnam a number of times
and you know he was he was very much a
progressive and he ran this
this uh this activist uh non-profit
called the international action center
and so i i was working with them during
the occupy wall street protests and
i started representing them on
international television
uh eventually um i started working with
a tv network called press tv which is
from iran and i started doing reports
for the from the un i became their un
correspondent
uh and then i started working with rt
and i've spoken at a number of
international conferences uh
in venezuela in brazil
uh in uh in ecuador in iran and in
russia
um and uh you know and now i've
moved ahead i want to start a think tank
dedicated to anti-imperialism and
socialism
and so that's what the center for
political innovation is uh it's about
you know spreading
a message of constructive optimistic
socialism in these dark times
trying to build a world where we can all
come together to raise living standards
and
end poverty etc
yeah there was a lot there in the
trajectory that
yeah that kind of pressure cooked you to
be what you represent today
so if you if you take us back
there are these situations where in a
sense
the essence of those situations was
seeing radical amounts of
inequity and of basic needs not being
met
people unable to actualize their fullest
potential
um yeah and lots of
also kind of perverse um
hierarchical dynamics um
like extractive dynamics of those that
are in positions of power
so would you say that that would be like
the
amalgamation of perversities that was at
play that that kind of triggered your
interest in
a greater meeting of needs i'm always
somebody who's wanted to investigate
things you know my mother was a
librarian and you know uh
before the internet was a big thing you
know we always had a world book
encyclopedia in our house you know all
the
all the you know encyclopedia and we'd
be talking about something at dinner
time and we went and got the
encyclopedia and you looked it up
you know and i was always taught to do
research and to investigate
um and to learn more and so i always
wanted to learn more
um and uh you know i think when the iraq
war broke out
and we were being told that saddam
hussein and osama bin laden were best
pals and had pulled off 911 together and
that there were weapons of mass
destruction and we were under attack
um you know i i investigated i learned
more about it and i learned that that
was not the case
and then i think when i went to ecuador
as a kid and saw so much
poverty and i had never seen that level
of suffering i wanted to know why it was
um you know i remember there was
somebody who told me at the time they
said well the reason that people are
poor in ecuador is because business
meetings don't start on time
is what i was told i was told that uh
well you know in the west we start our
you know in the united states and europe
we start our business meetings
on time you know the meeting is 11 it
starts at 11 but in ecuador
they start a half hour late an hour late
so that's why they're poor over there is
they're not as efficient well
that didn't make sense to me you know i
mean that that wasn't that wasn't the
truth
um and the more i looked into these
things uh the more i learned what was
really going on
um and uh it seemed like uh there was
you know a huge effort to you know kind
of lie and manipulate people and
the more i learned about communism it
seemed like i was thinking of this stuff
on my own i thought about health care
and how politicians always talk about
health care and i said
well why don't we just make sure that
everyone has health care why don't we
just you know like just like
the government make sure there's roads
the government make sure there's a post
office why does the government run the
hospitals and we just
you know we pay the doctors out of our
tax money whenever anyone needs to go to
the doctor they go to the doctor
and i would say that people say that's
communism i'd be like it's communist i
didn't know what communism was
uh but it seemed like you know uh you
know i'd see you know there was
unemployment as a problem why don't we
just
make sure everyone's hired and you know
put them to work doing useful things for
the good country that's communism
because we told being told that's
communism so that got me to go look into
what communism
actually was and read the communist
manifesto and learn about it and
the more i learned about it uh the more
interesting it was to me and i
i will never forget this experience
because everyone whenever they told me
about communism would always tell me
that
communism was this evil ideology it's
failed
everywhere it's ever been tried and it
just it makes countries poorer and it
doesn't work and all this
so i'll never forget um you know i went
to the library and i was i was wanting
to learn about communism but i knew that
you couldn't be
like stalin or you couldn't be like
lenin or fidel castro or these were
brutal authoritarians right
so i got a book called the revolution
betrayed by leon trotsky
and it was a book that was you know i
mean it's called the revolution the
trade i figure it's about
why you know the soviet union was not
really socialist why trotsky's teachings
would be
better or something like that and the
first chapter of that book is called
what has been achieved and i opened the
first chapter of leon trotsky an enemy
of the soviet
union a guy that stalin killed the first
chapter is what has been achieved and it
was all just economic data
statistics about steel manufacturing
statistics about about
coal production and and just i was
reading this and i was just like this
can't be true because everyone told me
that everywhere communism has failed and
i'm reading
he's describing how the soviet union is
becoming an industrial superpower the
biggest steel manufacturer in the world
the biggest
nation i mean all these people wiping
out illiteracy raising
i'm reading this i thought this can't be
true this has to just be propaganda
because everybody knows that communism
failed everywhere it's ever been tried
so then i went and i got the
encyclopedia and i read the section on
the soviet union about economics
and there was like a small paragraph
that said soviet union achieved you know
rapid industrialization
modernized the country i'm like wait
that's not what i've been told
and the more i dig i dug into it uh the
more
i learned that wow there were tremendous
economic successes
in socialist countries uh if you compare
the life expectancy of cuba
uh with the life expectancy of most
countries in latin america they're doing
pretty well
um you know and that you know china
under the leadership of the communist
party has gone from being one of the
poorest countries in the world to being
the second largest economy on earth and
an economic superpower
and that so much of what i was told
about communism this idea that
economically it just doesn't work it's
never worked anywhere
that was just malarkey as joe biden
would say it was just
false um and there are just many
examples of socialism
and centrally planned economies leading
to great economic successes
and so as i as i discovered that i
thought wow the fact that we've been
lied to
so much about communism means that
communism probably has something to
offer the same
people that lied to us about weapons of
mass destruction and lied to us about
saddam hussein and osama bin laden being
buddies they're lying to us about
communism so uh
maybe we ought to look into this and and
the central that was always the central
thing
i was told about communism no economic
successes ever
and that is just such utter falsehood
right i mean you can talk
human rights you can talk about other
issues there are certainly criticisms of
what went on in the 20th century but
lack of economic success is not one of
them uh you know and
and that the fact that we're lied to so
much
uh really indicated that uh that this
was something to look into so there you
go
i will also say that and for me one
moment that was very big in my life was
when
i i you know i went to iran for the
first time in 2014
the islamic republic of iran i was
actually quite afraid when i was going
there i've been heard this is a strict
religious dictatorship and i
you know i was deleting every file from
my computer afraid i might have
something that would go against the
government and i'd get arrested and
you know i was being i was being told to
be very careful i got to iran
i found a country that is yes i mean
it's you know there's posters everywhere
political posters you know there's
pictures of the supreme leader
everywhere
and the militaries have been part of the
country but i found a country full of
very friendly people that you know have
different perspectives about things
and then i returned to iran in 2015 and
i actually got to
accompany the red crescent society of
iran
to go to yemen uh to go to deliver
humanitarian aid to yemen
and i spent 13 days on a ship uh headed
for
uh headed for yemen with all kinds of
medical supplies and food on behalf of
the un
recognized you know red crescent society
um
we were on our way to yemen and then the
port that we were scheduled to dock in
was
bombed eight times by saudi arabia they
bombed it eight times in a single day to
keep us from docking in that port
and i saw the warplanes flying overhead
and
i heard all kinds of reports and
international media claiming that we had
weapons on our ship and this was a
smuggling a weapon smuggling operation
which it was not
and that was definitely a very spiritual
experience for me uh
and you know to spend 13 days on that
ship uh and then ultimately
go to uh go to um djibouti because we
couldn't dock in yemen
and have the ship unloaded by u.n relief
workers who saw that it was a big lie we
weren't carrying any weapons to iran or
to
yemen that wasn't the case it was purely
a humanitarian mission uh that was a
life-changing experience that i will
never forget you know and
and uh and seeing that and such so yeah
i mean there's been a lot of interesting
moments on my journey through life i
guess you could say
whoa
oh yeah there's always room
for improving the
planetary architectures that meet
basic needs and then enable everyone to
be actualized to just say that
there's a static system that is working
for everybody no matter what
is um it's not dynamic that's not
flexible and so we're we're right now
we're seeing that there's
these decentralized universalization
style architectures of fractional
ownership
and inclusive stakeholding which we'll
talk about um
in a bit i want to visit what you were
mentioning also
a moment ago about there are these
um across the planet we have um
we haven't really understood yet what
um oneness is or what unity
is and you talk about it like a
spiritual experience
because you know when you really begin
to not just go along with the spiritual
platitude that were brothers and sisters
you know even biologically 99.9
genetically similar and 0.1 genetically
different which is why
you look the way you do and i look the
appearance of form
is the only small tiny differential
um but everything comes from that
abiogenesis on the planet
everything comes from the cosmogenesis
everything is that one intelligence
and so when we sort of begin getting
that then you don't have this
you don't have this malevolence of of
bombing
and of scarcity mindset rather than
abundance mindset
um and so that this is a this is this
sort of
consciousness awakening is
um it goes right there hand in hand
with spirituality with meeting basic
needs with
seeing everything as one and so um
yeah because that that type of story
those types of stories we
we're gonna come to the end of those as
we recognize more and more
um of of the oneness and so that was
also coming up and
um one other thing that came up that i
thought was
really relevant was as you were going to
iran and having this
experience of so much fear dogma
being peddled to you about your visit
in 2019 i also went to
china for for partnership interviews
with peking university and west lake
university
in beijing and hangzhou and
i was also just peddled so much fear and
dogma
and uh it was so great when people were
like you know don't take your computer
uh all this same stuff and i was just
you know breezed right past that and i
made these
incredible friendships and connections
just an
incredible um country that has so much
awesome hospitality awesome technology
awesome culture
um and it was so welcoming and it's
really important to make friendships in
iran
to make friendships in china in saudi
arabia in russia
in whatever countries around the world
because
we want our friends and families to come
together
because that has nothing to do with what
mainstream media
is promulgating with fear narratives and
so that that seems to be another
critical thing is don't go listening to
fear-peddled media that's feeding these
limbic
infrastructures that's making us more
and more
fearful of the oneness but rather go
directly
to the friendships with people in other
places in the world
and recognize right there when people
invite you into their home
have some tea have some food have
enjoy some music together go in sightsee
go to the local museum
play some sport you know that that's
that's how we
foster this oneness and this and this
love and so
that was also coming up to have have you
also
noticed you know as we get into the
other topics have you
also noticed that that being a critical
pillar globally is both um
um really flowering and blossoming these
relationships between
families and friends across the planet
but also that
sense of unity and that sense of oneness
sure well when you talk about that sense
of oneness i'm forced to think of
the book civilization and its
discontents by sigmund freud
um which is you know it's one of freud's
most important essays
um and in it you know freud talks about
how you know he's
you know he does psychoanalysis he's
interviewing his his clients and
that a number of his clients who are
religious uh have told him that
they have this feeling of oneness with
the universe this universal feeling
um and it's that feeling alone uh that
gives them the feeling of being
religious and sigmund freud can't relate
to this at all he says i don't know what
they're talking about i
i don't feel this at all and he doesn't
know what it is
um but in the book he he talks about
this a lot and that's a big
point of the book is is him trying to
make sense of this feeling of oneness
that his
his clients experience um and uh
and you know i i think that's
interesting because i can relate to that
you know i feel like that feeling of
oneness
is is a big part of my life and striving
for that feeling of connection
with other people and with the entire
universe itself is something that i
i've struggled to do quite a bit um and
what i think is interesting
is uh you know in my book on kamala
harris i wrote a book called kamala
harris and the future of america it was
reviewed pretty widely and
you know it's there's not many books
about kamala harris um i quoted from
that and i talk about
you know what it means to be a leftist
or what it means to be left-wing
uh in that book because kamala harris
you know i mean you know she is
you know was a vicious prosecutor in
california jailed all kinds of people
for smoking marijuana
and then laughed about it when you know
and when asked if she'd ever done it
you know i mean she you know kamala
harris you know is is a pretty kind of a
sadistic person
um but you know but she grew up as a
leftist i mean her parents were both
left-wing activists and such and
then i argue in that book that left-wing
politics uh has
two sides to it um that on the one hand
left-wing politics is about striving for
that feeling of oneness and of community
right
and getting beyond the greed and
individualism and selfishness that kind
of comes between us
but on the other side of it there is
kind of a destructive side of left-wing
politics which
can just be kind of giving people
permission to release their impulses
right um and that as you know the left
is kind of talking about lifting social
restraints and
you know getting people giving people
permission to be angry giving people
permission to to be less uh controlling
of their own behaviors
um and i argue that that in the history
of
communism as we've seen we can see both
of those things that i would argue like
you know the french revolution
and uh you know the great terror and the
cultural revolution in china these
events were very much about giving
people permission to
unleash their rage and destructive
impulses
whereas you know the strength you know
when i talk about the soviet union
rapidly industrializing when you talk
about china becoming a superpower when
you talk about cuba's health care system
the strength of socialist countries has
been not their ability to unleash
people's rage and
anger but rather their ability to strive
for that feeling of oneness and
community
um and what i think is also interesting
is that you know the socialist movement
you know in the 20th century was very
much an atheist movement because
religion was identified
with the ruling class religion was
identified with feudalism and the feudal
structures that they were dismantling
but nowadays that seems to have really
changed uh you know
the leader of venezuela nicholas maduro
is roman catholic
um his his predecessor hugo chavez was
also roman catholic uh fidel castro
converted to christianity during the
1990s and had confession with the pope
uh nicaragua the slogan of the
government is christianity socialism and
solidarity
um and in the middle east you know the
both socialist movement uh that was
syria and iraq
they gave islam a special recognition in
their
constitutions even though they were
secular governments uh gaddafi was very
much a muslim
um and in iran they they insist their
system is not socialism or
capitalism they call it not capitalism
but islam that's what they refer to
their system as
um but it is very much a system where
the state controls the means of
production and
operates them for the benefit of society
they have these local councils in every
neighborhood called prestige
and you know i mean they don't call it
socialism but it's very much not a
capitalist country and not a capital
system but
spirituality is a big part of it um i
think that's very interesting and i know
even now in china
there's been a revival of confucianism
um and the confucian tradition you know
the culture
during the cultural revolution mao very
much uh you know played up the idea that
confucius was the old society and they
were getting rid of it but now
you know in modern china xi jinping and
the chinese communist party argue that
kind of
confucius and mao kind of walk together
and part of unique what makes china
unique and kind of china's unique
identity that's separate from the west
so i think that we're seeing kind of a
shift in how communists and and leftists
and anti-imperials relate to issues of
religion
and spirituality and we're kind of
realizing that that
destructive impulse right that desire to
tear things down and unleash your rage
uh while that may have been useful to
communists you know in in the 20th
century to come to power
uh you know that may have been useful
you know in the time of karl marx when
they were fighting against feudalism and
the remnants of feudalism and the
tradition of the french revolution
but now those destructive impulses that
maybe played a revolutionary role at one
point
have been hijacked by imperialism and
hijacked by
by the western capitalists um and very
much social media
uh and a lot of the the you know the
forces coming out of the west are very
much about trying to unleash people's
destructive impulses to create chaos and
instability to incite people against
each other
so that we can all be ruled over by wall
street in london and the you know the
emerging financial orders silicon valley
etc
so really the socialist movement is
changing its orientation when it comes
to how it operates psychologically
that feeling of oneness is becoming
central and those destructive impulses
are becoming
something that is being recognized to be
problematic and my book city builders
and vandals in our age that's a point
that i i made throughout that book uh
was that
it was kind of me analyzing this and
figuring out where are we in the 20th
century because the cold war is over
the soviet union's gone uh what you know
the old school
marxism leninism is not really you know
a big force in the world but there is
very clearly a difference between the
east and the west
there's very clearly a contradiction
between western capitalism and the
people of the world that are striving
against it so what's
what is the new difference about and i
argue this is this is city builders
and vandals uh and that this is the city
building tendency the constructive side
of the human species striving for that
feeling of oneness and creativity
uh and the destructive you know side of
the human species that you know was kind
of hijacked by the roman empire and then
later by the british empire
this is two sides of the human spirit
and the human soul facing off with each
other
uh as we kind of are hitting a turning
point created by the computer revolution
and technological progress
we're hitting a turning point where
capitalism is not a sustainable system
any longer
millions of people no longer have a
place at the assembly line
we have to change our mode of production
to survive and so now we're seeing these
two
sides of the human psychology coming out
and kind of
playing out on the global stage and
clashing with each other
yeah it's like a
there's a chunk of civilization that
has
at least had a taste of unity
outside of like their nuclear family
that's usually where people
begin getting this uh taste is like when
you have a child
you become automatically a little bit
more selfless
and so then there's that feeling and
then usually you have like a friend
and then your friend goes through
something that's emotionally
catastrophic
and then you hold space for them and you
empathize and
um you have that sympathetic well-being
that you're
um helping them go through the process
and so you like you slowly
become you know more and more awakened
to
how humanik is are sharing an entire
civilization and planet and how we're
sharing it with 10 million other
species um and that we
are breathing in the same oxygen
that the phytoplankton and trees are
enabling us in the photosynthesis
process to
to inhale and so there's
you know what there's so many
interdependencies
in that oneness web that exists
that um people slowly
wake up to them and then it's not only
people like grassroots doing it but also
people in positions of leadership around
the planet
waking up to that and like you're saying
there's all these different unique
tastes they're like different
combinatorics where you have
one like that's china one that looks
like russia one that looks like saudi
arabia one that looks to get like the us
but then like you were saying in your
book that
you'll always have people that are
interested
in um oneness and engineering and
prosperity and that type of stuff
and you'll always have some other people
that maybe are a little bit less awake
and more egocentric
and that think that you know by going
out and vandalizing things they can have
a bigger megaphone in sharing their
messages and ideas
and but really if they were to create
architectural changes and go through
these more oneness states of
awakening then they could make much
greater
impact and so because ultimately it's a
dialectic
where it will have um this conservative
and liberal in a dialectic and
ill constantly be fluxing and
you know or the individualism and
collectivism you know fluxing
in ascension or the u.s and china um
science and spirituality and so
um to sort of take the best of both and
merge them
and uplift them is really what you know
we talked about that in
chapter seven of one of the visual books
that that we wrote called high level
perception was called the sorting
algorithm it covered this exact
exact topic so it's actually important
for viewers as they're watching this
video to look
in inward and look at what's going on
inside
where am i feeling
any hatred or ill will or malevolence
towards
towards people that don't have the same
beliefs or ideas as me
and how can i um
feel more whole and feel more one
with people that may have a different
set of ideas than i do
and how can we equanimously calmly
lovingly even sit down and just have a
conversation
about you know what are some of the good
things that we can maybe take from both
of the viewpoints and see what kind of a
project we could
um put forth into the world so there's a
much more if you look at two kids
playing right the little kid
from china or iran or or argentina or
the us whatever
that these kids when they're playing um
that there's no there's no concepts and
ideas
and that are like twisting and
distorting their lens of
of perception they still feel like
innocent playful
children on planet earth as one and so a
lot of it the journey
also to oneness as an adult is to
um to become more innocent and to become
more
um open to
a planetary harmony but in order to do
that like we're talking about we
need um to hone in on the basic needs
being met around the planet people
can't be starving and not have access to
clean water and not have
fractional ownership in um
the companies that they're actually
building as
employees but that they're getting no
fractional ownership of
the company and so there's a
that could be a good um way for us to
venture
so this seems to be a main
tenant we could say potentially of
um of cpi in general
um so here's the
the center for political innovation
and so when you guys go to this page the
links in the bio cpi
usa.org and we also talked about this
quite a bit on the show
with ryan cotton um you can look at this
four-point plan
to rescue the country and that you have
um mass mobilization to rebuild the
country public ownership of natural
resources public control banking
economic bill of rights and so what
you'll see here
you know you see a pretty continuous
theme
you know this public ownership public
control
um and so this would probably be a good
way to
talk to caleb about this is that
it seems like the i the idea it's it's
more like a really it's like
more like a biological archetype really
when you look at
the way that fungal networks talk to
trees
underground in a two-way resource
exchange or how
um the internet evolved or how
decentralization and cryptocurrencies
are evolving
um that it's very decentralized it's
very universalized and there's
more and more desire now across the
planet
for people to have fractional ownership
where we have like andy bittner was just
on the show
and so he has the actual architectures
that enable people to contribute
uh funds towards their city's
uh regenerative energy infrastructures
and then they become fractional owners
they get dividends
um all this type of good stuff and so
there's um
there's a whole new suite of of ideas
that are very like oriented in our
biology
that are up and coming and it seems like
that seems to be a core
aspect of cpi is um public ownership
everybody getting a share of the pie not
like
um and we also i think you're
you're familiar with this we brought
this up on the show with uh with ryan
as well the wtf happened in 1971
uh.com um this is the
this is the bifurcation of of median
mail
income with uh real gdp
per capita in 1971. wow um
yeah and so we're
this uh this one is a pretty
good visualization of it and yeah and so
there's
we're shifting away from this where
more and more people um are are
flatlining
meanwhile a very very few people are
reaping
um the vast majority of fruits so
would you say that that's a core essence
of cpi that style of architecture stuff
sure well um i think that the issue
again
with when it comes to the issue of
natural resources
right you know the way
the country's natural resources are
operated
has a very big impact um it has an
impact on the environment it has an
impact on communities
and on top of that it's one of the main
sources of wealth
uh you know oil natural gas coal timber
i mean this is how people make their
money
and all throughout the united states you
will find communities in pennsylvania
and ohio oklahoma and alabama
where the people are just getting poorer
and poorer and poorer
but fracking companies and
you know logging companies and natural
gas
corporations and oil companies are
getting wealthier and wealthier and
wealthier
and why is it that the communities where
these resources come from
are being economically devastated but
yet they're generating more wealth than
ever before
why is this happening well it's because
the this natural wealth
i mean it's just you know in the soil of
the united states or
grown this wealth is in the hands of
private owners
uh and so the communities all around
this wealth can get impoverished uh but
the people
uh the people uh you know they they're
not not getting any benefit from the
natural resources
i mean this is all over the world too i
mean you know
nigeria is a very wealthy country it is
the top oil exporter in africa
but if you look at nigeria especially
the niger delta region
where most of nigeria's oil is extracted
the people there live in just utter
poverty
because that oil belongs to exxon mobil
and vp and shell and chevron it doesn't
belong to nigeria and the profits from
that oil
and the management of that oil is all
you know being done for the benefit of
these corporations
and uh so the idea is that you know as
our country is getting
poorer and living standards are dropping
et cetera that maybe this should be
changed and maybe the way
uh the oil and natural gas and coal and
timber the country has operated should
be
strategically planned out by the
community for what's in the interest of
the community and the wealth
you know the profits generated from
selling our natural resources should go
to the community
uh rather than to these private owners
who are operating them only in their
interest and
when it comes to banking it's a similar
thing right um you know
every major religion christianity islam
judaism
has has forbid the lending of money at
interest
and there's a reason for that because
the lending of money at interest leads
to a group of people
who make money by having money uh they
they have money and then they lend some
money to somebody and they get more
money
they didn't do anything nothing got
created in the process you know and they
they make money by having money then
pretty soon they become exponentially
wealthier than everybody else
and governments are in debt to them and
the whole economy is centered around
these people that make money by having
money
right and it's something you don't want
to have in your society so
i would argue that credit should be
centralized
in the hands of the community whether it
be the local community the state
community or the federal community
and if when people you know they want to
buy take out a loan to get a house will
they make the case to their community
that it would be better
they had a home they want to start a
business well they make the case to
their community that my
business will benefit the community and
when they pay back their loan
then the the interest instead of going
into the hands of a private owner goes
into the public budget and it takes the
tax burden
off of the community right and we can
use that money to build more schools and
hospitals and such and
and it's about having an economy
organized for the
for the community overall public
ownership rather than
than for a small group of private owners
who can you know
continue to enrich themselves while
society falls apart right
if the landing of money and the control
of natural resources were done
you know collectively with understanding
that we need to benefit all of society
i think we would have a much better
economic result than simply letting the
chaos of the market
the anarchy of production handle these
things
gosh that's such a good example with
natural resources across the planet
giving the example um
in africa there's many other examples
like this
where you you just you
you need people to have their basic
needs being met
and the resources are coming from those
areas
anyway yes yes there is a
upfront investment from a wealthier
part of the world that comes and and so
they
get a fraction of the pie as well but to
take the vast
majority of the fraction and give nearly
scraps breadcrumbs to the region
is absurd and it's um in its exact
so again when you recognize that you can
take rather than a hundred billion
dollars over 10 years
instead you only take 25 billion over 10
years
and that other 75 billion would go into
the
local economy because again that's not
different than you you've only assumed
that those people other people are
different
than you are but you're not because
you've assumed yourself to be separate
from this one
intelligence that everything is and so
that's really important to remember
for all of our um especially wealthy
uh people around the world is that that
that that is
you that is you that extra um meeting
basic needs is literally going to
you actualizing your fullest potential
in that
that part of the world sure i mean
i think that the health of one is the
health of all and this pandemic has
really proved that right i mean
you know if the government had responded
to this pandemic by saying you're on
your own folks uh we would
we would have a little bit of a problem
wouldn't we you know and that you know
the health of one
is the health of all and when when
people in a society are unhealthy the
whole society around them gets unhealthy
and we human beings are collective
creatures we work together
in groups uh you know we were tribal at
one point we built civilization
since then you know i mean we've always
been collective creatures
and i would argue that individual mental
health is very much tied into how you
relate to other people
uh you know um you know people that
suffer from schizophrenia you talk to
them
and probably the main issue that they
have going on is their ability to
communicate with other people
has been kind of destroyed i mean they
you know they they're not able to
communicate with other people
effectively
they kind of exist more and more and
more in their own kind of isolation
where they start to develop delusions
and
such um and that that a lot of mental
health is
problems that people have in their
relationship with other people you look
at
the personality disorders you talk about
someone being a narcissist you talk
about someone being
histrionic you're talking about
borderline personality disorder again
these people it's not they have a
problem with themselves that you know if
they were alone on a desert island they
would have the problem the problem is
the way they relate to other people is
tainted and often that can be from
trauma or bad experiences that they had
or
where you know they had you know parents
that brought them up to see the world in
a certain way but
you know but but mental health is very
much tied into other people and if you
look at since the pandemic
as we've had the lockdowns and all that
the rate of depression and anxiety in
the united states has multiplied by four
we are having four times the depression
and anxiety we had before well why is
that
because people have been social
distancing they've been isolating from
each other
and the more people are separated from
each other the more they're cut off and
the more they're just kind of left alone
uh that
the more unhealthy they're gonna be the
more you can connect with other people
the more you can be part of a group
and feel like you know you're able to
have empathy and share other people's
interests the the healthier you're gonna
be
um and that that understanding of mental
health i think is very important and
then increasingly we've been taught to
view mental health
from a biological standpoint right um
you know if this person's depressed or
anxious they just have a chemical
imbalance
well if you look at the number of people
that are taking antidepressants in our
society
right now this is not simply a chemical
problem this is a society-wide problem
i think that the rugged individualism of
western society this belief that you
know everyone's on their own
you know you know you know sink or swim
pull yourself
up by your bootstraps this has taken a
toll on us as a country
uh psychologically i think it is it has
hurt us as a society
it's had a very negative negative impact
human beings are collective in nature
and now we're at the point where we
can't even really mobilize to address
society-wide problems right i mean you
know all the different capitalists are
trying to make profits for themselves
and
all the different government officials
are tied to different factions that have
different agendas and you get a
situation like the pandemic you get a
situation like the country's crumbling
infrastructure something needs to be
done but no one can bring themselves to
do it because
again we're all kind of doing this
individualism thing you know and and
individualism isn't inherently bad we
needed a kind of a wave of individualism
i think to bring down the feudal
you know hierarchies that existed you
know in medieval europe
right to have a new level of freedom as
a new level of economic development
uh you know created a situation where it
was possible to have freedom of speech
and freedom of religion and freedom of
assembly that yes it was necessary to
push for a new level of individualism
you know in response to uh to the
oppressive feudal systems that were
holding back
social progress but now we've entered a
stage where this radical individualism
and the philosophy of individual
liberalism which is the politics of of
individualism and i
don't mean like democrats like liberals
i mean you know philosophical liberalism
economic liberalism is
free markets you know uh social
liberalism is freedom for the individual
but
but both of them emphasize individualism
above all else and
it's kind of a rejection of collectivism
liberalism is kind of out of control and
we've forgotten that we are one human
species and that uh that
the you know the future of all mankind
is tied up together and the world is
more connected
economically speaking than ever before
we're tied into each other you're on one
end of the country i'm on another but
we're talking to each other right now
the potential for us to be more
connected to each other and tied in with
each other
and to really care for each other and
really work together to
you know achieve everyone's potential is
higher than ever before um
but we're being held back i think by the
economic base which is
profits in command capitalism and i
think that's holding us back and i think
we need to move beyond it and have a
more
collective economic system that can then
allow the human species to become more
creative and solve problems as we never
have before
yeah so well said
there's a
one of the core things that you brought
up right there that i think's
instrumental is that
you have what appears to be
so many different
individualistic interests that are
blossoming where
it's completely different where two or
three or four
people want to create different
music or science or whatever people want
to do but
when you have um like you were
describing
fortune 500 ceos and congress people
and that are wondering well how do i
extract for myself that's a completely
different expression
than is how do i make some great music
or some great
engineering or whatever and so
we that that whole extractive cadence or
rhythm that we've been kind of flowing
with
has been um it's it's really come to
this point of
just a big pressure cooker to snap us
out of that style of
relating with each other in a way that
is okay this is a separate person i'm
talking to a separate person right now
and my objective my goal is to extract
as much as i can for myself in this
situation
and that is like that's
insanity um and then you take that and
you port that over into two countries
talking across the planet
and that's even more insanity and so now
the conversation is
more about you know you you have that
con
as your in that convo it's
this is one
engaging with itself and because i know
that
we will come to an understanding
where both of us can have our basic
needs being met where both of us
in our countries as well around the
world can have the natural resources
that we have in those countries be
serving
our local basic needs and also
be have fractional ownership
so that the whole pie can blossom that
the whole flower can
can blossom beautifully where you know
in
in 10 years we should hear about
djibouti and their incredible art and
their incredible science their
incredible
prosperity um and that that's that's
really caring about the brothers and
sisters across
across the world that when you know that
that you want
that story so badly that you're willing
to
sacrifice your like we gave him that
example your 75 billion extra that you
were gonna take
to instead take 25 billion and give the
other 75 to that local area
and let them prosper let them actualize
yeah cpi is a great way to do that
because
it basically um it basically takes the
um everything that we're talking about
right now and puts it into
practical architectural implementations
would you say that that's
that's about it that's the idea um you
know so much left-wing material
uh purely focuses on what people are
against
uh you know i'm against this i'm against
that i'm again
well i i my vision for cpi is rather
than focusing on what we're against
focusing on what we're for putting
forward concrete proposals
to address the problems facing the
country um and getting people beyond
just this kind of angry
you know we need a revolution we need to
tear things down aren't you mad i'm mad
too yeah we're all mad let's be mad
together
but rather what concrete proposals can
we put forward
and bring to our elected officials and
people in our community and say this is
what we're for this is what we need
um and it's not just uh those four
points that were also
uh in favor of fusion energy right uh
the climate crisis
makes it clear fossil fuels are not the
future of the world
uh but fossil fuels the reason that the
fossil fuel economy is still
in effect is because the world economy
is centered around wall street in london
wall street banks and london stock
exchange entities
are are tied in with the global oil
markets i mean if you
if you get on an airplane that's oil you
get the car that's oil
anything plastic in your home that's oil
right
oil the whole global economy runs on oil
and the oil markets are dominated by
four corporations exxon mobil bp shell
and chevron
right and if you include the french
company total the french oil company
you're talking about 80 percent of the
world's oil production right there you
want to talk about an ultra monopoly
those five corporations are 80 of the
world's oil supply
so that's an ultra monopoly and they
don't want to give up that ultra
monopoly they're at the top of the world
right if anyone wants oil they got to go
through them pretty much
um and that's not a good setup and
fossil fuels are not good for the
environment
it's not good for the world but what is
their solution
it just so happens they have all the
wealth so they get to pay for the
the environmental movement in the
climate change movement and they say oh
we'll just go backwards you know what i
mean we need to reduce consumption uh
all these people around the world they
got to be poorer hey this country in
africa they want to build a
coal power plant well that's not good
for the environment so you can't do that
you just got to keep you know without
electricity because
it's for the environment folks you know
they stop environmental projects and and
and you know power plants being
constructed and such in south africa and
many places
well i would argue the solution to
climate change is moving forward
what we need is to get beyond fossil
fuels to fusion
energy right the fusion energy
look china they are huge supporters of
fusion energy russia even though it's a
natural gas
and oil-based economy they still they
strongly call for global cooperation
around fusion energy
iran is working on fusion energy we've
got some scientists here in the united
states like dr eric lerner in new jersey
and there's you know there's facilities
in massachusetts and elsewhere who are
working on it
we say that that fusion energy should be
a united
global effort right all the different
people working on it should we should
have a new like u.n type territory
at the u.n you go to the united
international territory the u.n it's
like right over there it's like three
blocks away from where i'm at now
but it's not part of the united states i
have to show a passport if i want to get
in there because it's an international
territory
well we need to build a kind of a fusion
energy united nations in the center of
the american heartland in kansas
or iowa i think we need to just carve
out some territory
and then have a united global effort
every country that is working on fusion
energy flying all their scientists we
supply them with all the resources we
need to work
day and night to get fusion energy it's
an emergency we need to get off of
fossil fuels
the only way we're going to get off of
it is to get to a higher higher fuel
source that can generate energy more
efficiently we're not going to
you know win windmills are nice i'm not
against windmills i'm not against solar
panels but they're not gonna solve the
problem
only fusion energy really is beyond
fossil fuels is stronger than fossil
fuels
that is gonna solve the problem and we
need to have it be a global effort we
can't have it be a competition
where china is competing with us and
we're competing with
it needs to be a united effort so that
when fusion energy is achieved
it it results in all of humanity sharing
and the benefit
so that it doesn't become that one
country has fusion energy and uses it to
dominate other countries right rather it
should be one
cut one you know human community
developing fusion energy
and as a species we come together and
get beyond fossil fuels
um that's what needs to happen uh and
and it's going to happen i mean we are
going to get fusion energy
sooner or later but it needs to happen
as soon as possible
in order to alleviate the suffering that
we're seeing around the world in order
to get off of the
the outdated outmoded fossil fuel-based
global order
um we need to get beyond that and uh we
need to have a unified vision for
humanity and fusion energy is
is a big part of it so the construction
of what we call fusion city
this vision of fusion city we call it we
call for the creation of fusion city in
the center of the united states an
international
joint manhattan project not to build a
bomb
uh but instead to you know rescue
humanity from fossil fuels that's one of
our
central beliefs is we need to build
fusion city um
and uh that's a solution it's not a
problem you know what i mean and that's
that it's a solution to a problem and we
can now go around to different
politicians
and different elected officials and
different people that are talking about
climate change and say what about fusion
city are you for a fusion city
or are you against it and if you're
against this tell us how could you could
possibly be against this project
you know that's what needs to be done we
need to raise the alarm
uh about the need for fusion city and
again by putting forward what we're for
now what we're against what we're for
that's a way of bringing people together
that i think is is very effective yes
exactly what we're for we're for
meeting basic needs across the planet
everyone having access to clean air
water food shelter electricity
healthcare education
and where four uh
fusion technology were for uh shifting
away
from increasing the parts per million of
co2 um were against ocean acidification
again we're for
fusion and that automatically makes us
uh
pro oceans um as well which is great i
love that and a pro
environment pro uh keeping our tree so
again uh pro forest not anti
deforestation but pro forests
you know so there's all these different
ways to also structure
this um in this in story
that helps um people get it and i love i
love the idea of having a
un-style um international
global effort on fusion
and plopping that down in kansas or iowa
um bringing some of the best from around
the world actually remember how i
mentioned west lake university in china
in hangzhou that's basically what they
did there they made this
private public partnership there in
china
and they brought some of the greatest
scientists from around the world
there to start their labs and
really interestingly rather than some of
the other universities around the world
where
if you make some sort of great
innovation the university keeps it
um that at westlake they have agreements
like a 50 50
ownership if you make a great innovation
or advancement
and so that would be another big core
thing at the
fusion city facility yeah is something
like that to incentivize the scientists
and engineers and researchers and
technologists
to gain a
greater amount of ownership in what is
created as well and then for
um for that technology to then go and
empower
all of the car
flight cargo ships trading
across the oceans all of the different
um use
that we use today like you were also
mentioning plastics is another big one
um and so because you see all these
different indigenous communities around
the planet
that are basically saying guys what are
you doing
like don't you get what's happening
don't you see feel it don't you
recognize that you can't
everything's so deeply interdependent
the hydrological cycle is cyclic and
interdependent you can't just take a
poop
and then expect it to not come back and
rain on top of your house
you know you you gotta you can't just
make a pacific garbage patch in the
ocean and not expect it
to feed back into you know we're we're
having these parts per
trillion of these pharmaceuticals being
discovered in our water supplies now
there's all these different types of
things that that we just can't filter
out through sanitation
right now and so we need all these like
basically x prizes
in a sense right so we need the cpi's
four point plan
we need a crowd source innovation for
that we need the
xprize style dynamics across the planet
the style of global coherence around
these big initiatives
um yeah this is great and and i love
also the the practicality of
someone that that currently is wondering
okay well how do i
get involved in cpi how do i get
involved in
infractional ownership how do i go from
somebody that is barely making my basic
needs be met
what would what would you suggest well i
mean you can sign up on the website
uh you just go to cpiusa.org and we have
a form if you want to get involved and
we will plug you
in um i think you can just go to uh you
know
join cpi and uh there you go um and
right now you just fill that form out
and we'll get back to you
um and we have around the country uh in
many parts of the country people have
formed reading
reading groups around our textbook this
is our textbook we are
city builders uh the center for
political innovation educational manual
um and uh you know it's uh
it's available um and you can get them
in bulk and people have been reading
this book
and discussing it people have been doing
zoom discussions of it there's people in
australia discussing it
uh there's a chicago reading group of it
that just started there's a group of
people in
in san angelo texas they call themselves
san angelo solidarity they're a group of
activists latino
and white uh and they they gather once a
week and they read from the manual
um and uh you know there's uh there's
also a reading group here in new york
city there's a reading group
in california in los angeles that's just
starting
um you know i mean we people are coming
together to discuss this book
uh and to kind of use it you know as the
basis
for for trying to you know to put the
vision of the center for political
innovation into effect
um and the reading groups around this it
gets people talking the point of this
book is to get people talking
um you know after every section uh
there's questions
uh and the book you know it's not simply
there's an essay by me about city
builders and vandals but there's also
there's an uh a speech by roosevelt in
the book there's a speech by henry
wallace
who was the vice president uh at one
point uh uh and and ran on a peace
platform
uh you know in 1948 against harry truman
uh
you know there's there's uh there's
stuff from mao zeitung the founder of
china in it um
you know there's uh there's an essay by
edward bellamy uh who wrote the
the science fiction novel looking
backwards like a bestseller in the 1880s
which was about like a futuristic
socialist america and what it might be
like and we have one of his essays
called the parable of the water tank
uh in in the book that's included and
it's just and we have albert einstein's
essay why
socialism is also included in the book
um and the book is designed to get
people talking about these ideas that
the center for political innovation puts
forward and people are reading it
uh and discussing it and some people are
doing it online some people are having
meetups
and that's one thing that you know if
you can if you want to get involved in
the center for political innovation
that's one thing we can definitely help
you to start do is start having reading
groups around this
this book um but we're also having
educational seminars around the country
uh that we're starting to do um you know
with the pandemics a little difficult
but we did one in pennsylvania that was
very successful
that was at the end of june um and we're
about to do one in in california
um you know it's already pretty much
full at this point which is exciting
because uh you know i mean but it's but
it's happening and uh
and as things open up and we can start
having you know using big spaces and big
auditoriums and such we want to start
doing
doing them all across the country i mean
some people want me to go to ann arbor
michigan
people want me to go to chicago people
want me to go to texas uh we're
making this happen we have a team of
people that are on the streets of new
york city every day they're called the
john brown volunteers named after the
great anti-slavery fighter john brown
who kind of gave his life and the
struggle to abolish slavery
um and you know they're out every day on
the streets of new york
we have buttons uh that they're
distributing that say uh cancel student
debt they say end the wars and bring the
troops home
and we have you know palm cards about
the center for political innovation and
about our four-point plan what we
believe in
um and they're out on the streets every
single day they're in the parks here in
new york city they're they're on the
subways and
and they're out there doing it and uh
they are eventually gonna start moving
to different cities around the country
as we have different events right now
they're based in new york because that's
where
most of our resources and our
organization is headquartered but this
is a team you know this john brown
volunteers group these are full-time
people this is their primary job you
know i mean they might do another job on
the side but they live together
collectively and they are dedicated to
this vision of building
building in america uh where working
people's needs come first and not the
profits of the few
and really putting our vision into
perspective so this is very exciting i
mean this is a very very exciting moment
and i feel like i'm at the beginning of
something very very exciting
you know um years ago people asked me
when i first started moving toward
building the center for political
invading the center for political
innovation
people asked me why i didn't form a new
party why didn't you just you know we
got the communist party we got the
socialist
party why don't you form a new party i
decided not to do that because
most of these parties are very very
irrelevant and there's way too many of
them
and they're competing with each other
and they don't like each other and
they've been kind of doing the same
thing for a while
and i've said to socialists in the
united states we need to get out of the
movement
and to the masses right we need to get
to average americans who've never met a
socialist before never met a marxist or
a leftist before
and find out you know find out what they
believe engage with them and put forward
policy solutions that can win them over
and we need to get out of this little
circle of leftists who've all known each
other for years and have their long
grievances against each other are you a
trotskyite are you a maoist are you a
follower of enver hosia are you an
anarchist you know get out of that
and get to average americans with a real
program
that could actually be implemented i can
see fusion city being built
i can see our four-point plan being
enacted these are things that if you
tell people you're for them
people can see them happening now i
think that
in order to enact them you know you
would have to really challenge the power
of big business
and in doing so i mean yes it would lead
to a transformation of society but these
are real concrete demands they're not
abstract philosophies abstract notions
these are real
policy solutions and i think that is the
way you know if you go to other
countries this is how
you know communist parties tend to
operate as they have their program they
have what they're for
and they run in the election advocating
things like what we're advocating jobs
programs
uh meeting people's basic needs
construction etc
um that's that's how they operate here
in the united states
communist groups will give you this big
answer about we need a revolution to
tear down the old system or something
that's not real politics
uh you know uh you know and and we need
to get serious right i mean that's why i
wear a suit for goodness sakes you know
people say that me wearing a suit
people find that to be odd well serious
politicians wear suits
you know and uh you know when i was
working with a labor union
uh years ago uh they oriented their
their
labor union organizers to wear suits
because you know that
to show that they're serious right and
that we need to
you know less and less sound like you
know hippies that are screaming against
the man
and more and more sound like we're going
to be running the country someday
because i think
we will be i think that people running
the country will be influenced by the
center for political innovation we're
not a political party we're not running
for office or anything like that
but i think that our ideas will be taken
seriously by politicians
uh i think we will have an impact uh and
i think that we need to act like it we
need to act like we want to be taken
seriously
cool the sounds like there's actually a
pretty good
amount of access points that are really
um fundamental like we are city builders
is a great
one and then also just um getting
involved in those like smaller knit
communities in the different cities
and then getting involved with joining
cpi as well
and then um coming together i think yeah
ryan was mentioning that you guys have
an upcoming
in santa barbara conference and that's
the one that's already
full yeah it's pretty full i mean
limited space and with the pandemic
restrictions and stuff but we want to
start eventually you know just having
big auditoriums
you know i mean why not right i mean we
have this team to go out and promote it
and
that's that's kind of the idea right is
that there is so much
interest in what we have to say i mean
the amount of interest that we've
generated just in
in the you know we've been operating for
about a year i think we've been having
weekly zoom calls
the amount of interest we've generated
the amount of fascination with what
we're about and interest and the amount
of people who contacted us and wanted to
get involved is not a small number
people are hungry for this right i mean
this is this is marxism
sure this is socialism this is you know
these ideas are not necessarily new but
we're doing it in a new way
people in the usa haven't been doing it
this way for a long time
you know i like to think we come from
the tradition of eugene debs uh
gus hall and william c foster and the
black panthers and uh
and you know uh other other leaders
w.e.b du bois
we're from that tradition uh but we're
applying it in a unique way in our
unique times
and i think that's very exciting i mean
we have an optimistic vision
you know socialism is fundamentally an
optimistic philosophy it says we can get
to a better society
we can move ahead and we're trying to
bring optimism and constructive thinking
back to socialism
and then when when someone is uh yeah in
practical
technological advances like fusion city
and like this fractional ownership and
all this good stuff
when somebody in the city is given the
little
um pin and whatnot when it's
talking about um ending uh
wars and about bringing troops home and
about
meeting basic needs is the the action
point for them
is then to get signed up read we are
city builders
uh go through the zoom calls on the
weeks and then also begin sort of
putting out these octopus tentacles into
the different projects for
meeting the basic needs locally in their
cities and that type of stuff
that's right absolutely that is the idea
you know and uh
you know we've collected a number of
emails um you know we have
we've handed out at least at this point
at least 2 000 palm cards have been
handed out on the street
about you know they say we are city
builders we need a government of action
to fight for working families and
and we have collected lots of emails and
talked to lots of people
um you know and and that slogan that's
kind of you know you saw the four-point
plan but the slogan that we have used is
we need a government of action
to fight for working families uh because
we've been
you know we've had it pumped into our
heads that the government is best that
governs least
right that the government should just
keep its hands off let the economy
um you know take care of itself well we
argue that no
that the state and the government does
have an obligation to the people we need
a government of
action that will take action to protect
working families uh you know if a parent
you know uh in their you know is sending
their kid to school without proper
clothing
uh in the wintertime and they're in
their cold they can be arrested that's
called criminal neglect well i think the
government of the united states has
committed criminal neglect so many
people in this country are hungry
so many people are without health care
without education uh the roads are
falling apart
uh the water is not being properly
purified all of this
indicates to me that uh that our
government is in dereliction of duty and
we need a government that will step up
to the plate
and uh if you can go back to um go back
to long before
anything in the 20th century you go back
to the the 1400s and europe you go back
to the dark ages
during the dark ages the reason it was a
dark age
uh you know it's remembered as a bad
time
is because there was this notion that
basically people existed only to serve
those who were above them
uh if you were a peasant you existed to
serve the noble if you were a slave you
existed to serve your owner if you were
a commoner
you existed to serve the king but things
started to change
with the introduction of the notion that
it went both ways or the rise of what
you can call modern statecraft
you read the treaty of westphalia it
talks about how you know how the
sovereign
has an obligation to the people and you
you got some forward thinking monarchs
who said you know we really ought to
start you know educating our population
we really ought to start building
infrastructure
uh you know we really ought to start uh
you know funding and it was through
kind of governments that said actually
we do have an obligation to serve our
people
uh that's where we got the music of bach
and beethoven and that's where we got
the the work of leonardo da vinci
and uh that's where we got uh the uh the
you know the um
uh you know the work of shakespeare you
know what was shakespeare's uh
you know his theater troupe what were
they called they were the king's men or
the lord chamberlain's men i mean it was
the government said you know what we
want to make our people better
so we're going to start having plays
performed for them right and that
suddenly there became this notion that
the job of the government was not just
to have people serve it but it went the
other way around the government had no
obligation to serve the people and
that's what really got the ball rolling
with human history right i mean the fall
of the roman empire was very devastating
i mean you know it took europe
uh 1100 years to recover in terms of
population from the fall of the roman
empire
and really what was kind of the turning
point uh that got you know got us out of
the just the chaos and confusion
and and demoralization and pessimism
that came from the fall of the roman
empire and
got us back on the road to you know city
building and construction
was a change in consciousness this idea
that there is an obligation to serve the
people
and part of that was you know that that
among the elite there was some you know
there were some secret societies there
was some whispering and
you know the teachings of plato uh were
being studied and the platonic school of
thought was being studied and you had
you know uh chemistry and science being
taught you know the alchemical tradition
you know
behind the scenes and uh you know you
had finally you had
copernicus uh who is brave enough to
come forward and say you know based on
my research the
the earth is not the center of the
universe the sun is actually the center
of the universe and that was
you know he risked being burned at the
stake for saying that because the church
said the earth was the center of the
universe but he
with his primitive telescope and his
mathematical calculations discovered
that no
no you know the the the earth is not the
center of the universe uh
in fact the earth is revolving around
the sun um you know and that was a huge
breakthrough but
he wouldn't have been able to do that if
there hadn't been an effort
behind the scenes by by people who were
knowledgeable and skilled to kind of
whisper in each other's ear and support
each other and gradually get the ear of
some powerful people like monarchs and
start to change things around and get
out of the dark ages mindset
um and that's how things started to
change and i think we need to get back
to the notion of serving the people we
need to demand
that our government serve the people and
part of the neo-liberal ideology part of
the
the economics of adam smith and milton
friedman and friedrich von hayek
uh and alan greenspan and iran part of
their thinking is the government should
just keep its hands off well i think
that's fundamentally wrong
the government shouldn't keep its hands
off the state has always played a role
in pushing excuse me pushing society
forward
and the artist i would say has an
extremely important role you know
and one of the problems that we have in
our society now is that art
is commercialized right and when art is
commercial
it doesn't want to take risks right um
if you're if you're
if you're an artist right if you're if
you're making movies or you're right
making music and all of that you need to
be able to try to do things that no
one's ever done before
right if you're gonna you know be a part
of art is you have to do something new
but the problem is that a capitalist
always wants a return on their
investment
and and sometimes when you do something
as an artist as a painter
as a poet as a musician as a sometimes
you're going to take a risk and it's not
going to work
and and so if it's purely about making
money
um the problem is that you know you know
you're not going to get the funding the
person funding is going to say no i need
to make sure i get my money back on this
so no you cannot take that risk
and it used to be that the role of the
artist was to try and make society
better the artist's job was to make you
smarter
make you better with the art they were
teaching you they were engaging you they
were
forcing your mind to go to places that
have never gone before etc
but now art does the opposite in order
to guarantee that it will sell
it kind of takes things to the lowest
common denominator
um and that's the opposite of what art
is supposed to do
i've talked many times about how i feel
like uh grotesqueness
has taken the place of creativity in so
many areas right
nowadays so many movies you know instead
of coming up with a comedy it's just
brilliantly funny and makes you laugh
they gross you out and you kind of laugh
because you're grossed out instead of
coming up with a horror movie it's very
scary and suspenseful instead they make
a movie full of blood and gore that
grosses you out and then you're like
grossed out
so you're kind of scared right instead
of making an action movie it's so
exciting and all that they just
gross you out with a lot of violence and
you're kind of grossed out and that
they've kind of discovered that grossing
you out and making you kind of gag
and kind of shocking you uh can take the
place of what
you know good art has been doing for
thousands of years right um and it and
it takes the work out of it too because
it's like an easy filler
um and that's a problem and i think that
we need to get back to
the notion that the artist has an
important role in society you know that
the tv
what goes on television should be should
be done in a way of trying to make the
country better
not trying to make profits for
advertisers and the same for the music
and the same for the
for the poetry and and the same for
theater and and the same for
for art art has a very important role in
teaching you how to think
um and uh yeah i mean and you know i'm a
little bit critical i like i've been to
a few wagner operas
and i like wagner's music but i i
recognize that wagnerian music is very
much about emotional manipulation
right you know it's about emotional
manipulation he's emotionally
manipulating you
but that if you listen to bach and
beethoven it's a little bit better
because
they're not emotionally manipulating you
they're forcing you to kind of pay
attention to the patterns that they're
making in the music
and and it can have an emotional impact
but it's a much deeper one
because you're intellectualizing it
first it's not simply like hitting you
on the gut level
it's hitting you on an intellectual
level the pattern of the notes and
what are they going to do next hits you
on an intellectual level and then
by through the intellectual process
you're then at that point uh
you know you're you're then you know
responding to what you've learned from
the music in an emotional way
and it has a much better impact on you
and i think that's the important thing
as well that
that you know when we talk about art
being pornographic i mean it's not
literally like
naked people but it's appealing to you
simply in a climactic sexual
in a way just driving emotions into you
and
that can be a little bit problematic you
want art to appeal to you in an
intellectual way that stimulates you
makes you think and then gives you an
emotional response
yeah this is the beauty of meeting basic
knees is that then you get
all of the great explosion in art and
also
when when we get people like the
um 2 200 billionaires across the planet
that wake up more and more to the
oneness you get great things like what
the medici family like you
listed did with you have michelangelo
botticelli
and da vinci and
galileo and you get that big explosion
of renaissance
and we want more artistic scientific
spiritual renaissance to happen and
the only way to really truly do that is
to just look at how
like mycorrhizal networks work how do
fungi
and trees do a two-way resource exchange
underground
because they know it's one intelligence
it 95
of planets work with fungus underground
and so similarly
that's what we're talking about with
this wealth being able to
in a sense create of more of a
fractional
meeting basic needs in creating the
fractional ownership
within the social contract so that like
these smaller seedlings in the
understory
they have these mother trees that then
this is great work by suzanne simmer
that they send the extra that they get
from
from photosynthesis they make extra
sugar sending it
to and sending carbon to the extra
seedlings and
and smaller trees in the understory
and that that's that's a great way to
visualize what could be
the um the meeting
more basic needs and getting more of the
renaissance
to be activated and it's it's
exciting like feeling into what will be
possible artistically scientifically
spiritually as
as that happens and like use that as
good fuel for yourselves
i love that and this is probably a good
place to
also ask you about on our on our way out
just to ask you about
um you do you see because ryan and i
spent some time talking about this on
the show as well and i wanted to mention
this with you
um so
so science and spirituality or another
way to view it is like materialism and
consciousness
that they are two sides of the same coin
they're not actually inseparable
things this is how i'll be curious to
hear your take on this
that they play into one another where
basically
um especially given what we're talking
about with cpi and stuff
you need the external architectures
to be met like your basic needs in order
for you to actually be able to
have metacognition and some space to
actually think about your thinking
and stuff like that but you
also in a sense need to turn
inward towards your consciousness and
become
more aware of oneness and become more
aware of that so that then that can play
into your architecture of the material
world do you see those two interplaying
like that well i think
what you're saying is that when you give
people when people are able to have
their basic needs met
that gives them more space to then start
to look inward
and that's absolutely true in my own
life my own life experience i mean there
were times in my life where i was
struggling to get by economically
selling my blood plasma working at gas
stations barely making enough
and just you know at that point was i
dealt i was like doing deep inner work
and thinking about what my motivations
are no i was just trying to get by
and it wasn't until things in my life
got a little more stable and all that
that i was actually
able to do some you know reflection and
look inward
um but i also want to say when you talk
about you know spiritual and materialism
you know it is interesting because you
know i mean when i first got involved in
leftist and communist groups you know
they are very they tend to be very
atheist
oriented right and that the marxist
philosophy is dialectical materialism
all that exists in the in the universe
is matter but that matter is constantly
in a state of motion
um and you know there are some marxists
that even go as far as criticizing
einsteinian physics and saying that
einstein says
matter and energy are separate and
that's a spiritual conception all the
matter is just energy and that this is a
big part of the marxian philosophy
but it was really when i went to iran
and i went on that ship to yemen
uh that i had a spiritual awakening
because i realized you know when i was
on that ship
for 13 days and we talked about religion
a lot you know and those folks are shia
muslims
and i'm from a christian background it
was when i realized at that point
uh that uh that you know i wouldn't have
been on that ship if it hadn't been for
growing up
as a child and every sunday going to a
church and hearing about jesus
and hearing about jesus christ and how
he laid his life down for his beliefs
and and how he called on his followers
to to make a life of sacrifice
and and if it hadn't been for my
christian background
i never would have become a leftist i
never would have become a socialist in
fact
i remember when i was in college there
was a librarian at my college was kind
of an older guy he spoke chinese
fluently
and and he had a wife from vietnam and
he was an older guy and i remember he
used to say to me and say you know
he said you sound like a communist he
says but i think deep down you're still
a christian and i would say that's
that's crazy what are you talking about
he said no i said he said i hear
christianity in you
uh and i didn't know what he meant until
i was in iran years later a decade later
i was in iran
and i realized that here i am and that
so much of my life
is is you know is rooted in jesus
christ's teachings
and my belief that there is something
bigger than myself i was just in this
for my own personal gain i'd you know
started
you know a company that makes porn
websites or you know selling opium or
something
you know you know what i mean i mean
it's like you know it's like i i'm
clearly
motivated by something higher that i do
have a spiritual drive behind a lot of
what i do
um and that forced me to realize that
that seems to be one of the problems
that the soviet union
had and that a lot of these communist
countries that were led by atheistic
governments had is that
that by rejecting religion by
seeing everything in this purely
dogmatically materialist lens
by doing that uh they were kind of not
understanding that people are motivated
by something higher
and if you even think about like the
great communists uh in history
why did che guevara do what he did and
take take all those risks and give up
everything
why did he do that he didn't have to do
that it wasn't in his material interest
to do it
but uh you know but he did it because he
felt driven by some kind of higher power
of some kind of inner spiritual force
right and he probably was an atheist and
would if you just said to him oh god is
inspiring you to do this he would have
said well that's crazy
but i think there is there is an inner
spiritual drive i mean and that
there are higher higher motivations
people can have throughout history and i
even reflect on my own life
some of the decisions i've made in life
that have been very very good
decisions have been ones i didn't think
about i just did it
you know i mean like you know when uh
you know uh and
then i think about that and i think well
how did i do that right well it's like
you know
you know and i think all of us you know
they talk about i think you know quakers
uh uh they talk about the light within
right and i think all of us have access
to some kind of higher spiritual energy
um but all of us also have our bodily uh
you know
crass human desires you know and that uh
in a lot of ways
uh you know it's it's a question of
listening to our our
you know our higher spiritual side or
listening to our lower cross human
desires and
and and figuring out who we are and
listen to the light within learning to
listen to the light within you
um you know one of the most beautiful
pieces that i've ever read
uh is the uh is the uh the the uh the
fedo
by socrates and this is the dialogue
that socrates gave
uh when he was facing death uh you know
when he found out he was being executed
he was going to be executed he was going
to have to drink um
drink hemlock and he he it's the
conversation it's just a transcript
of what he told his followers while he's
waiting to be executed and he's sitting
with his followers and he's doing like
one
last study session with his followers
before he gets
you know he gets the death penalty um
and he's sitting there and he engages
with them and the first line of it is so
beautiful he says when he found out he
was going to be
killed he said the same dream came to
him sometimes
in one form and sometimes in another but
it always had the same
message which was go forth and make
music
go forth and make music and he
interpreted that to be
do as much teaching as you finally can
uh before you
you leave you leave this world you know
um and it's really really beautiful and
you read it
and he's getting his his students to
understand that
we human beings we have our animalistic
bodily desires but we also have a soul
we have a higher part of ourselves and
that what he was trying to get his
students to do as a philosopher was to
listen to their inner light and
this is beautiful stuff and this is
really a big part of of
how i've come to understand my life and
where i've gotten and how i
i got from where i from from ohio to
occupy wall street from occupy wall
street to iran
from iran back to the united states to
setting up a think tank you know
it's been reading reading that that
dialogue has been very important to me
and and
helped me again do some reflection but i
would argue that the more you know
yourself the more you can know the
people around you
right that some people think well this
is all just inner reflection
no the more you know yourself the more
you can then
help yourself to relate to people around
you that there's a connection right that
uh that these things are connected so
there you go that's my answer to that
yeah that's great the inner light is a
great way to
see it because when you
when you see the inner light
as what is underneath of all of our
costumes
that's another great way to get to this
feeling of oneness
and uh and that's what we share you know
when you when you talk about just
awareness
or consciousness itself um pure
bear empty um
that is what we share like this is
consciousness talking to consciousness
awareness talking to awareness and so
the intelligence talking to the
intelligence life talking to life
reality talking to reality
light talking to light and so when you
really tune inward and and feel this as
well you
you get that this light is going to
reflect the more that you touch this
light within it's going to reflect
in the external architectures and the
more that the external architectures
become meeting basic needs the more
people can turn inward toward the inner
light
and i love that um feedback loop that it
has
and that's why that's why we had this
show and that's why it was so important
to feature you
and to talk about cpi yeah and to and to
implement
um the four-point plan and to actualize
it
and um and to get more and more of
america in the world engaged in
unity and in the basic needs
architectures
amen all right well thank you very much
it's really been a pleasure to come on
your program and i this was a very
fruitful discussion we went to some very
interesting places
good brother i'm so glad to hear that
and
by the way everyone um we love you very
much
thank you for tuning in we're so
grateful we've been
we've been watching the live chat you
guys have been having a great
conversation in there we would
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments also
below so drop us a comment and let us
know how you feel about
um the video you like the video if you
brought you value subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
share the video with other people with
your friends family get them inspired as
well
and all the links in the bio um
we have also we have caleb's youtube
channel
he's actually quite oftenly doing
streams
on the channel as well um and talking to
america on the streets
um at the state department uh briefings
and this is some of your work with
rt as well yeah cool
and then talks presentations interviews
and so you can find um this link in the
bio below
you can also find caleb on twitter
uh and that links in the bio below as
well
and then um also his
author page on amazon you can find that
link in the bio below
and cpi for
getting signed up checking out the four
point plan here
and also going to join in the top corner
and so that uh i think that that covers
that covers it um
yeah that covers it excellent it was fun
i i wish you the best and and this is a
great channel you're doing great work
here atlas
so thank you very much thanks caleb yeah
i'll go ahead and i'll wrap the
um the studio and and then we'll we'll
stay
we'll stay in the studio and talk i'll
click and stream here in a sec thanks
again everyone for tuning in
infinite love talk to you soon